Maryna charac has taken her campaign
against sexual violence to social media
this Facebook logo she designed says I'm
fighting rape culture the message has
found enormous resonance online around a
million users in Brazil including
suspended President Dilma Rousseff have
posted it to their profile page women
are used to dealing with machismo but
the gang rape here in Rio has really
tipped things over the edge a huge
amount of online solidarity reflects
this frustration it's only really coming
to light now but the fight isn't just
taking place online today marinas
attending a protest against sexual
violence in the center of Rio
the gang rape of a 16 year old girl
captured on video and shared online sent
shockwaves across Brazil as women we've
either experienced sexual violence or
had friends who've been victims of
sexual violence is a reality for women
that's why this issue has spurred so
many people to take action we want this
reality to be recognized and for women's
voices to be heard thousands of people
have turned up to protest many of them
are young women who say change can't
come fast enough a woman is raped every
11 minutes in Brazil Marina says young
people need to be educated about sexual
violence children and young people
should learn to understand the opposite
sex to start talking about sexual
violence against women early on that's
the only way to change the rape culture
the public outrage has prompted the
government to take some action those
found guilty of gang rape will now face
longer jail terms but marina fears
Brazil's new conservative lawmakers
aren't committed enough to stamping out
sexual violence for good